plays it out to Johansson TI to Center dub breaks
that up with a pass over to cadri so du up with z
and cadri as Pils out of the lineup with the
return of Walker D here's poo with a chance
and that one off the goal post and that was
stopped by vard poo thought he'd scored the
puck play back to the line terrific save by blar
was down on the ice back in the lineup there's
the turnover watch this play by he's going to
attempt go outside goes back inside and it is
on solv what an incredible move by Felino as you
mentioned Rick is third of the Season that is a
terrific start for the Minnesota Wild starting
a four game Road Trip there's no question that
is in yeah zeri takes the puck feeds it across
salob off had to get away here's Freddy Gro back
in front chance for Maroon stopped by lard big
save there by D to keep it a one goal game watch
this little turnover then goodro is going to spot
maroon he's going to go backand high and lard is
Johansson back to Bod quick shot blocked by TANF
Erikson gets the Pu hold in front lar makes the
save off broin and hangs on for a stoppage just
past the six-minute mark right in the slot and
watch this fantastic save off that grade A Chance
by nothing more to prove at the AHL level so a
chance maybe to get a handful in while Mar's out
for Dustin W nice pass here and goic there's a
shot by m japani and a blocker save by gson swings
in wide turned back B over Faber takes a look to
the circle shot Off The Stick of weager well wide
BBY throws it in front pad sa lar on the backand
by Eric Erikson e is going to get an opportunity
right in front and he goes back and another big
save two-on one by the Flames unfortunately the
players couldn't find the groove here's a chance
now there's a shot turned away as working the
puck towards when that was Conor do another big
save by vard to keep it a one- nothing game fires
a pass over one timer by Capri off and that was
stopped by Vadar as he came across to make the
save LS break out three of them over the line
but mon here's chance mon to save by goson and a
penalty coming up as well now watch this little
play gets it to lyol right back to mapani does
that hit the post first Rick or is that no no
Spurgeon feeds it around mino's on it Minnesota's
penalty kill has been terrible this year it's the
worst in the league 70% here's a chance short
hand and go it's Foo again lard made the save
15 ft out of his crease and you're going to
see a bit of a bad rebound now he's a little
bit slow and coming out and Felino has a open
that that is a great great desperation saved by
Vadar all right Rick that's already 30 seconds in
and that's a different team that maybe the best
30 second points of play tonight more hungry Z
Carell turning with a pass over shot off the post
they score capriso tucks it in as the first shot
hit the post and a tap in for Carell capriso to
make it two nothing here's that Rossi he's such
a good player he's going to hang on to that puck
gets a puck from zukar I believe which will be a
600th point and see the puck go off the Left Post
and capriso is just to the left of the goenda say
that that was zuk carella with the second assist
so that's his 600th point in the National Hockey
League if I'm not so they play again on Thursday
against Carolina and as Ryan mentioned it's an
afternoon game on Saturday against the devils
so you would assume although there's a
shot the score it's Baldi sneaking one
in two goals in the first 90 seconds of the
period and the wild have blown this open to
a three nothing lead and backing not strong
along the wall here's baly weager gets it and
then just sort of GS it right back at Baldi
who is had a really difficult year by the way
31 goals last year and here's that release
from boldy that's what they've been looking
for HTO hustles over to it spins back to
Anderson with a reverse backhander here's
weager BLS it across weager shooting this backin
with a tip and Michael bin gets Calgary on the
board and how about Hoover the P backand pass
to Anderson he gets it to weager and what we've
seen throughout this year he sifts that one
through better than anybody on the flames right
now and a beautiful redirect by the captain
Michael backlin Spurgeon back zuk Carell high
slot Carell capriso stopped by wolf gets it back
feeds it over another save by wolf rebound Capri
off again that's blocked by Anderson took it up
high really well there's that Capri off right in
the high slot there gets a one-time one more time
and he's going to get it over over to Baldi great
chance how about Rasmus Anderson Minnesota gets
its top unit out there now as Baldi Cuts in over
the line with a drop pass to Spurgeon zuk Carell
down the boards thedes it back Spurgeon plays it
over Carell capriso they score baling with a tip
in on the redirection gets his second of the game
and it's a power play goal that makes it four to
one wild the number one unit watch them move this
Puck around you see Baldi number 12 get right in
the open open up his stick blade and a beautiful
redirect Capri off with that beautiful OneTouch
Pass baly open up the blade which allows that
puck to elevate and they beat Dustin wolf lubero
intercepted by Eric s Han had to get away short
handed breakway chance for Brandon d right in STO
by wolf great pack save by wolf off to Hy weager
goes to the front of the goal Off the Bench
is Hanahan in time to take the puck Hanahan
in deep with a half minute to go in the period
now backman in the circle across here's hman
stop Coleman on the rebound that's stop to cson
got the right pad down the response you want and
then watch Noah hanen goes all the way behind
the net comes back out front has all sorts of
time another win by cadri solovov again this time
he makes a move cuts to The Middle on the back
hand with a shot score salob off they have been
tipped by Zer and the Flames cut the lead to two
with an early goal in third copio watch this
play on maroon whoops dances right around him
he's on the backand there's Zer in front with
a stick on the ice oh yeah that's a beautiful
redirect by Zer if that sticks not on the ice the
right time hassle by Middleton ties up RKA stick
and able to bank it out the center ice put back
in by weager tumbling Pock poke through here's
D GL save by gson he did get the second assist
on that goal with the clean face off Wi here's
tan throwing it in front that's broken up by B
us as two in this game flips it up Tan's on it
passle by Johansson Johansson steals Tanana
takes a spill Eric with a shot he's SC wolf
was spun around by nazam cadry's teammate and
juwel Erikson e puts Minnesota Back on Top by
three they have the puck good four check turned
over by Johansson and watch nazm cadri he loses
an edge and goes sliding right into Dustin wolf
he's trying cadri trying to dive and take away
that passing attempt unfortunately he Dives
right into the goal tender and now wolf he's
compromised he can't get his footing gson arette
Walker newer trying to cut it off had his pocket
pick by zuuk Carell and here's Pino weager Falls
it's a two-on one wolf with the save off the
throw they wave off icing
not quite enough anyway and
it's four in a row for the Minnesota
Wild under new head coach John Hines